goby is back with a spiteful Li filled
new book that's poured fuel on the
Flames he says that Megan wrote private
letters to King Charles naming two
Royals who she accuses of taking part in
those supposedly troubling conversations
about Archie skin color scobby says he
knew the names of the accused Royals but
couldn't use them for legal reasons
that's in the English version of his
book then as everybody now knows the
names suddenly appeared in a Dutch
translation
the only crisis I think that we're
facing at the moment this end game as om
scobby puts it is an end game for Omid
scobby I'm going to cut through all this
crap I'm going to tell you the names of
the two senior Royals who are named in
that Dutch version of the
[Applause]
[Music]
book good evening from London welcome to
P Morgan uncensor 2 and a half years ago
the dukee and Duchess are sat down with
Oprah Winfrey to Heir a slew of
Grievances and claims about their old
family that they had deserted the most
incendiary claim was that members of the
royal family had raised quotes concerns
in multiple conversations about what
skin color baby Archie skin would
be and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's
born what about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like hold up hold up there coms
there several conversations there's a
conversation with you with Harry
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look
like and you're not going to tell me who
had the
conversation I think that would be very
damaging to them okay compartmental
concerned that if he were
to
Brown that that would be a problem are
you saying that I wasn't able to follow
up with why but that if that's the
Assumption you're making I think that
feels like a pretty safe one you see
that's just an allegation of racism
right there it's not ambiguous that is
Megan marle accusing a member of the
roal family of being racist judging
somebody according to the color of their
skin and how Brown they are there's no
room for thinking it's anything
else now the impact of that claim was
extraordinary the claims were reported
breathlessly across the world tens of
millions of people hundreds of millions
were left with the unavoidable
impression that Britain is a racist
country with races at the heart of our
royal family but just the fact that
there is according to both of them this
ongoing blatant racism not only in the
UK tabloid press but in the family but
for some people in this country a
blanket denial of racism like the one
that we heard from Prince William
yesterday just isn't enough Buckingham
is racism among the more shocking
revelations was that sort of overt
racism she faced within the royal family
but here it is a couple that's truly in
love and the thing that you want to
question is their skin tone I hope all
those people are having severe second
thoughts or buyers remorse about
believing what mean Markle and Prince
Harry said I don't need to because that
day I said I didn't believe a word of it
and I had to leave my job because I
didn't believe them even though I think
they were lying well for two and a half
years there's been frenzy speculation
about how who these supposedly racist
Royals are just about every single
member of the royal household has been
implicated in the rumors at some point
and that surely isn't fair is it just
guilt by Collective
Association especially if you believe as
I do as I've always said that the claims
in my opinion are completely and utterly
baseless that speculation reached fever
pitch again this week because of this
weasly lick spit omed scobby he's the
client journalist of the sussexes he's
always the first to publish their Soviet
Style official statements and defend
their indefensible deeds he's like that
guy comical alley do you remember him
who fronted up for Saddam Hussein in the
Iraq War would literally say we've got
him on the run as the American howt say
we're coming over his head well Mega
marle famously denied briefing scobby
for his last book Finding freedom but
then she was forced a few months after
it came out to apologize in court and
admit that actually she had she briefed
one of her aids to go and tell scobby
all the L all the laundry so when it
emerged that the leg's book contain new
details on those race accusations well
let's just say I've made my own
assumptions about where scobby could
have got that information from because
it wasn't King
Charles so that only leaves the other
person on the end of that correspondence
that's megga Markle or maybe Harry her
husband or maybe one of their mutual
friends the scobby keeps boasting he has
scobby says he knew the names of the
accused Royals but couldn't use them for
reasons that's in the English version of
his book then as everybody now knows the
names suddenly appeared in a Dutch
translation of the book and by appear I
mean they were sent to journalists who
couldn't believe what they were reading
they went into bookstores where people
could buy it well last night I decided
this was all ridiculous and it was time
to name the two rules implicated in
those racism claims they are as I said
last night King Charles Prince Charles
as he was then and Catherine
Princess of Wales I did that for several
reasons first the speculation was once
again raging out of control as it has
for two and a half years second it made
no sense that Dutch journalists and
Dutch people who bought copies before
the publisher withdrew them would know
these names members of our royal family
when the British people were prevented
from knowing them thirdly once you know
the names it becomes blindingly obvious
to anyone with even half a brain that
these allegations are ridiculous
whatever your view of the monarchy I
don't think any serious person really
believes that anything they've seen or
heard from King Charles or the Princess
of Wales suggests they have even the
tiniest racist bone in their bodies or
would judge anybody according to the
shade of their skin and once again it's
worth remembering what Prince Harry
eventually said about these accusations
when he was promoting his book and
before we play the clip just to remind
you after launching This Racist
bombshell 2 and a half years ago
it never got mentioned again not in the
six-part Netflix series which mentioned
everything else in their lives not in
the 12-part podcast for Spotify that
Megan marle did never mentioned and it
never got mentioned in Harry's over 400
page book 150,000 words of stuff about
his entire life but not a mention of the
supposed racism by members of his own
family which he had launched as a
missile against that family on Oprah
Winfrey so this is what he said to Tom
bradby at ITN at the start of this year
when promoting the book where he didn't
mention
it in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well the British press said
that right I did did Megan ever mention
that they they
racist she said there were troubling
comments about concern about his skin
color right wouldn't you describe that
as essentially RAC I wouldn't not having
lived within that family God he's such a
dim wit isn't he he's just dim as
ditchwater he literally thinks we're
going to watch the clips back from Oprah
and not think that she was saying that
the royal family had been racist how
dumb does he think we
are so Harry performs this dramatic
U-turn oh it was never we never meant to
suggest they were racist it was the
terrible British press they were the
ones who said it was racism we just
meant unconscious biased you know what
that's become a euphemism for we
actually haven't got any evidence of
someone being racist we just think it's
kind of unconscious on the sly right
it's kind of there but we can't prove it
it's like we think they might be yeah
not good enough not when it comes to
members of the royal family his
reputations are on a global
stage so why should I stand back and let
a proven liar like Omen scobby a man who
claims in this book as a fact that I
have regular phone chats with Queen cam
regular do you know how many times I've
spoken to Queen camiller on the phone in
my entire 58-year life
zero not
once it's not just not regular it's
never
happened we've never had a phone
chat so he's a liar and he lied again
about when apparently I called Mega
michael princess Pinocchio on that
fateful last day good Morning Britain
apparently ciller immediately contacted
me to thank me on behalf of the firm no
she didn't another lie complete
lie so SC be prepared to lie about me
about these little things which don't
really am amount to a row beans why
should we believe anything else he has
to say all he's doing is dragging the
whole royal family through the mud all
over again reigniting these racism
charges because he wants to sell books
and make money well scobby gave another
interview this morning to this morning
in which he again denied working with
mega marle and he also denied ever using
the names that any draft of his
book I'm as frustrated as everyone else
I make it very clear in this book that I
in every way possible want to adhere to
the laws surrounding this subject it's
why I've been very careful in how it's
described in the book and it's why I've
never spoken about it
beyond what I've said in the public
domain before the reality is though is
that this is information that is not
privy just to
me a liar a bare Fai
liar he wants us to believe that he only
submitted a draft in the English version
which never mention the names but that
somebody in the Netherlands got hold of
it and added the names and added entire
paragraph in one part of this into the
manuscript before it went to the
printers a lethal
sabot who would do that have you ever
ever met any author in history because I
haven't who's had that happen to their
manuscript on the way to the printers in
a foreign country like the Netherlands
they got into the manuscript and changed
it without the author knowing anything
about it no it doesn't pass what we call
the smell test it's disob stinks when it
comes to the smell test now he thinks
I'm completely wrong to assume in an
earlier version of his book included the
names and was sent for translation only
for his lawyers to take them out of the
final Edition which I think is the most
likely explanation it's therefore rather
inconvenient for him the Dutch
translator has told reporters tonight
that she'd only translated what was
written down on the manuscript she said
the names of the Royals were there in
black and white I didn't add them I just
did what I was paid to do and that was
translate the book from English into
Dutch now at this point the deafening
Silence from Harry and Megan becomes a
little more than deafening it becomes
pretty shameful because they usually
race to condemn and denounce any press
reports that we dislike particularly if
it involves any leaks from private
correspondents Mega marle ironically was
forced to admit that she colluded with
omis scoi on his last book in a court
action she took against a newspaper over
private correspondence with her father
so why have they remained So Silent
about omis sco's lies and also about his
leaking of the private correspondence
between Mega Markle and King Charles
that contain these names is it because
they were involved in him getting this
information is it because I don't know
the tooth the came down and did it or
Santa Claus or for want of a better a
better third example
Pinocchio the public can of course make
their own minds up about all of this it
shouldn't take long and the same goes
for the baseless accus ation of Royal
racism nobody I repeat really thinks
King Charles or the Princess of Wales
are racist nobody that's part of the
reason actually why I decided to put
their names out there it's called
Lancing the boil it's called removing
what has been a simmering threat
deployed by Megan and Harry and deployed
by Omen scobby as an unspoken threat
we've got these names and if we if we
don't get what we want we're going to
use them well now they can't do that
I've been at the sharp end of British
journalism for 30 years I've seen World
chist he's come and go I remember after
Diana died everybody predicted that was
the end of the monarchy but it wasn't
the monarchy survived and it thrived
with our great Queen Elizabeth II and
it's doing so again now with King
Charles who's doing a brilliant job as
the head of our great royal family and
the head of the great monarchy the only
crisis I think that we're facing at the
moment this end game as omis scobby puts
it is an end game for
scobby so let me start with you Tessa so
given you normally park yourself in the
defending the indefensible about all
things susex what do you think of scobby
late just when it seemed like they were
getting off the radar bcam scobby uh
with a series of apparently damning
Revelations about all the Royals apart
from the two in monteo yeah from all the
extracts that we've had access to and
from the interviews that omid's done in
the likes of a Parry match uh certainly
he's parked his tanks firmly on their
lawn Queen Victoria recommended against
Royals having friendships and if Omid
was once the sussex's friend I bet they
could flick him off like slime right now
because the timing is terrible and I
feel that Omid is actually behind the
curve on this while you've moved on a
bit I think I'll give you credit and
Harry and Megan to an extent I think
after the sort of bomb of the the the
Netflix and the book have been really
quite stum Omi seems to be sort of stuck
in the past well also he's a liar and
I'll tell you how I know he's a liar
because he writes a bit about me in the
book I know I was going to ask you about
that I got a copy of the book today and
I just checked as you do it's a digital
copy I did a little search up I come
three or four times and on one occasion
he States as a fact that I have regular
phone conversations with Queen Camila
for the record I have never had a single
phone conversation with Queen Camilla
now he says as a fact in his book that
we have regular phone conversations that
I know personally know is an absolute
lie he also says that when I said on
Good Morning Britain that Mega marle was
Princess Pinocchio uh that apparently
she reached out to me Queen Camila to
thank me for standing up for the firm I
had zero contact with Queen Camilla
around that time at all so you no
embosed thank you notes from Camila
before she was a queen is there any
communication I did however as I said
publicly the time have conversations
with several other members of the Roy
family but it wasn't Queen Camila so my
point let's come to Hillary Hillary I
know personally that just the little
bits about me are completely untrue
they're lies so why should I believe any
of this
stuff well you're absolutely right to
question it I remember the time that you
said that if she uh told you the weather
you wouldn't believe her um a few things
here I would say they say if you're
going to lie be big go bold he States
things so actually that I think your
average person of course they can't sift
through things they don't know that you
know that these were um mistruths and
that boldface lies so if he goes so big
people will actually almost assume it's
got to be true I'll tell you something
though Piers that some someone that
nobody really is mentioning and no one's
talking about and that is Megan markle's
dear friend very close friend that she's
posted online whom she loves and that is
Marcus Anderson well as we know omed
scobby has a very close relationship to
to him who knows how much of this is
actually coming from him and maybe
that's the source of a lot of these whom
he's quoting it's a really good point
because we know we know because she went
under oath in a court case Mega marle
had to admit she briefed an aid to then
brief scobby and the co-author and what
about this Tessa there's a point in the
book where he talks about the contents
of letters between King Charles and mega
marle in which two members of the royal
household
I know who they supposedly are right
these two people let's call them Royal
household that two of them had expressed
these Infamous concerns about the skin
color of uh baby Archie before he was
born right but my question is obviously
he's not got that from King Charles no
so he can only have got it from Mega
marle or her friends or people she's
told this to right so you know it's two
things this book one is blatant lies
secondly stuff he can only have got for
Mega Mar Harry and Megan's claims about
supposed racists and the royal family
have left a predictable and poisonous
Legacy for the last few years we live in
an age where grievances are given the
benefit of the doubt where the
establishment is Toxic by default where
my truth apparently means more than the
truth they knew the power their words
would hold and many people across the
world took their words at face value now
almost three years on Britain is still
dealing with the Fallout from this and
also concerns and conversations about
how dark his skin might be when he's
born what
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like hold up hold up there several
there are several conversations there's
a
conversation with you with Harry
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look
like and you're not going to tell me who
had the
conversation I think that would be very
damaging to them okay compartmentalized
concerned that if he were
to
Brown that that would be a problem are
you saying that I wasn't able to follow
up with why but that if that's the
Assumption you're making I think that
feels like a pretty safe one you may
recall that I lost my previous job for
responding to these claims by saying I
didn't believe a word of it well Harry
and Megan have never provided any
evidence for that highly incend claim
it's not like they haven't had the
chance to after all they pumped out six
hours of self-indulgent build on Netflix
trashing Britain and the press for its
racism but didn't mention what they said
on Oprah Harry read 150,000 words of
family bashing poison in his Memoir
spare and T the TV studios to promote it
they didn't mention what they'd said to
Oprah Winfrey megum had a 12-part
podcast on Spotify didn't mention it
either it's like it never happened like
it
disappeared clearly neither of them gave
a damn about rawal protocol or family
privacy in fact they buil a whole
industry around violating their own
privacy and that of their relatives
instead of backing up those claims about
racism on their Relentless publicity
tour Harry did a sort of strange U-turn
didn't he a few months ago tried to
prect they never said them it was it was
us it was the
media in the Oprah interview you accus
members of your family of racism you
don't even well the British press said
that right I did did Megan ever mention
they they
racist she said there were troubling
comments about concern about his skin
color right wouldn't you describe that
as essentially ra I wouldn't not having
lived within that family took him two
years to do that urn two years of the
royal family or a bunch of racists
flying around the world I was in America
through a lot of that period and they
all believed it because it had appeared
on Oprah and he says I didn't never
meant to say anything about racism what
are you all talking about it's the
beastly media well now Harry and Megan's
lick spittle client journalist omed
scobby the man who lied about his age
said he was 33 when in fact he was 38
bit older now said he never used private
jets and then got reminded of an
Instagram picture of him the week before
he denied that this week showing him on
a private jet the man who said that I
have regular phone calls with quink
killer regular phone calls never had one
phone call with Quin killer in my entire
life I'd like to but she doesn't call
well scobby is back with a spiteful Li
filled new book that's poured fuel on
the Flames he says that Megan wrote
private letters to King Charles naming
two Royals who she accuses of taking
part in those supposedly troubling
conversations about Archie skin color
scobby initially said he knew the names
but couldn't legally report them but of
course he could have done outside of the
UK he could have done it in America if
he wanted to where the book is published
could done it anywhere but he said he
never names names which is another of
his lies and yet overnight they were
sensationally revealed suddenly out of
nowhere in the Dutch version of sco's
book journalists had been sent copies
and the book was briefly onale
in bookstores before being suddenly
withdrawn in a dash by the Publishers
scob initially said it was a translation
error which didn't really make any sense
because how do you mistranslate
names they're either there or they're
not the publisher now says wasn't
translation it was simply an
error but how did that error happen how
is there an entire different version
appearing in a Dutch edition of this
book the consequence of the error is
that millions of people online around
the world now know the Royals are again
being implicated in what I think is a
completely baseless claim of inferred
racism there is again massive
speculation about who the people are who
were supposedly making comments about
Archie skin color which is incredibly
unfair to all the royal family they've
all been tired with this brush now for
years well I'm going to end all this
nonsense because frankly if a book is on
the streets in Holland available to
Dutch people containing names that omed
scobby the lick spittle scribe for the
Juke and dutches of Sussex the man who
you may remember denied they had any any
involvement in the last book and so did
Megan do you remember nothing to do with
it but then in court many months after
the book was published under oath she
had had to admit she had emailed her
AIDS briefing notes for when they met
scobby so she was one of his primary
sources on that first book now again
we're being told she had nothing to do
with this and maybe she didn't and maybe
we should be believing om scobby when he
says he did not ever write these names
down in any draft of his book it just
somehow popped up in the Dutch version
of the
book How I I've written 10 books I think
it is now I've never had a version of my
book pop up in a foreign Edition that
contained unbelievably damning
allegations about two of the most famous
people in the world and I had nothing to
do with it and didn't know how it got
there and nor did anybody else how does
it get there Omid surely you as the
author me you must be furious right you
must be demanding heads roll
and you want names don't you ironically
omed about who did this to you who smed
your reputation as an author I would
omed I'd want to know right now
especially if I was trying to convince
the world that I had nothing to do with
it myself and I'd never ever put these
names in writing and maybe some lawyer
had come along and told me not to I mean
that couldn't possibly have happened
because you've given us your word and as
I've established so far in this
monologue your word is your bond and
should be taken as sacr saint
well I'm going to cut through all this
crap I'm going to tell you the names of
the two senior Royals who are named in
that Dutch version of the book because
frankly if Dutch people wandering into a
Bookshop can pick it up and see these
names then you British people here who
actually pay for the British royal
family you're entitled to know too and
then we can have a more open debate
about this whole farog go because I
don't believe any racist comments were
ever made by any of the royal family and
until there is actual evidence of those
comments being made I will never believe
it but now we can start the process of
finding out if they ever got uttered
what the context was and whether there
was any racial intent at all like I say
I don't believe there was the Royals who
are named in this book are King Charles
and Catherine princess of Wales it's
almost four years now since Harry and
Megan made the groundbreaking
announcement they were quitting the
royal family stepping down as senior RS
moving to the United States and finding
Freedom well since that moment they've
systematically and relentlessly
exploited their existing Royal status to
make as much money as possible while
simultaneously trashing the Royals and
the monarchy to preserve their exposure
and relevance I think it's time we
brought the susic circus to a formal end
conservative MP Bob c is now introducing
a bill in Parliament to strip them
formly of their titles the Duke and
Duchess can be Mr and misses like the
rest of us he said someone doesn't want
to be a royal that's a decision we
respect they shouldn't keep the titles
and privileges if they trash an
institution that plays an important part
in our nation's life I think he's right
and as he also says the baseless racism
claims that are now embroil the king and
Princess of Wales well it should be the
final straw shouldn't they the author
behind those damning claims who claims
he wasn't the author behind those
damning claims but who else could he
have been the author of those damning
claims given it was in a manuscript of
his own book in which these damning
claims were made Sask lab dog Omid
scobby is still tying himself in the web
of his own lies yeah what a what a
series of events right um and what a
frustrating experience for me for a book
that was so heavily vetted legal eyes
dotted te's crossed and a book that I
was extremely proud of now completely
overshadowed by an event that has caused
me a lot of frustration ation as well
we've have a full investigation going on
into the series events that
happened yeah I know you're frustrated
buddy but um imagine how frustrated King
Charles is or the Princess of Wales that
somehow they got called racists in a
manuscript you claim you didn't actually
draft that way that's frustrating isn't
it when the entire world is encouraged
to think that you were named as racists
little bit more frustrating than you not
being able to work out why a draft of
your own book appeared in the
Netherlands and was translated from a
copy that had the names on it that was
sent to them apparently by your agent
how did your agent get that if you
didn't write it does your agent write
your book
Omid well the times has reported like I
said that earlier version of the book
did contain the names and it was sent to
the Dutch publisher Harry and Megan has
stood by and stunning silence so unlike
them isn't it when private conversations
of the kind that Megan had with Charles
in private letters began to circulate in
this book as well containing the names
of the two people that she and Harry
claim were racially insensitive about
the potential skin color of their baby
now these two can't normally wait to set
the record straight to sue to go to
court to hold people to proper account
for invasion of private correspondents
or
conversations why aren't they doing it
now they claim that they had nothing to
do with omis sco's new book but you
might remember Megan claiming that about
his last book and then a strange thing
happened she was suing the newspaper
ironically for invading her privacy over
private correspondence rather similar to
the situation we find ourselves in here
and when it came to the court case after
the book had been published that she had
nothing to do with with she was forced
to apologize because it turned out that
not only had she had something to do
with it she'd given briefing notes to
her Aid to go to a meeting with osobi
and brief him for the book so she was a
primary source for that book so I don't
know what you make of the Silence from
the sussexes we're into nearly week two
now of a deafening damming
silence weird right Tessa done lot
you've been seething away quietly to my
left I can see you simmering to simmer
away you will pull me peers occasionally
I think no he's found the light he's
seen the light he's no longer crashing
on about Harry and then this appalling
dir tribe we've just had to sit through
you claiming you lying there suggesting
that you're putting their names out
effectively to save the monchy you put
their names out for clicks you're no
better than omed scobby in fact you're
worse you call him Li spitt you're a
great big gar of fleem that's just
landed on the Royal doormat I don't know
how you slept last night I struggled to
sleep thinking about what you had done I
really can't and yes I did I did know
that you suggest there stop the perform
crap hly it's performance crap no let's
just hold on to calm down have a
civilized conversation the idea you
didn't sleep over this you don't even
know these people I was no I was
properly angry by your hypocrisy and
then you hpoc because you spend day in
day out your pro monarchy the wonderful
Queen wonderful Charles and then you go
and dob Kate and Charles right in it
when On's at 28 yes you did wait a
minute I'll tell you who did that omed
scobby because these names appeared in a
draft of his book which was published in
the Netherlands they were the line to
Netherlands tit tattle to you popped it
on a Mur do Platform and now you've just
had the goal to suggest
I know I am correcting the record the
record that was pe's highly dubious
opinion I've got a problem with you
tonight pears a real problem why would
you have a problem with a being on a
murd platform because what you did was
you put those names you're being paid to
appear yes I know but you took the name
the rumor the and you put it on an
official platform why you turned it from
fiction why you accepted money from a
Mur to challenge you about your behavior
and democracy and by the way just the
word Bas how do you know that Megan's
rumors were baseless how do you know
what she accused family any of it but
where's the evidence that it was
baseless where well obviously it's very
difficult two the chief WT they couldn't
even decide on Oprah Winfrey what year
these supposed conversations had
happened or how many there were right
they couldn't decide what year that
doesn't mean it didn't happen you take
notes and write in your diary something
happen let me get a Dicky I I just want
to come in you you mentioned the Oprah
interview and quite frankly Megan said
that it happened the conversation
happened when she was pregnant about 10
minutes later Harry came into the
interview and said it happened before
they were married so when did it happen
and did it happen and there's a big
question mark I will take issue with you
naming yesterday and I made that point
this morning um you are a bit of a law
onto yourself worse than a law excuse me
I didn't interrupt you actually just on
the law point it was entirely lawful
what I did so I did seek legal advice I
got very good sound legal advice and
actually there's no question I didn't
take the law onto myself I actually
applied a letter of the law this
information had been published in the
Netherlands Dutch people were free to
read it and I took a view it was
ridiculous the British people couldn't
be aware of this information I also said
when I named them that I didn't believe
a word of the racist allegations made
against them I didn't either I didn't
either didn't believe anything of that
that that interview it was just a dire
tribe of absolute nonsense as is the
book endgame and as you rightly say
endgame the only person end game is is
scobby but I did take issue in in
mentioning him last night yes you have
say the Brits have a right to know uh
it's in the Dutch uh translation
but there are those who will say agree
with you they will those who disagree
with you well many of the papers who've
held off apparently tonight are going to
name them you gave them no choice you
always got a choice sorry you always
have a choice everybody's got a choice
everyone has a choice everyone had a
choice when it was published in the
Netherlands not to repeat the names
right if they're all going to repeat
them tonight in the papers they were
just a day after us right and I have a
show called uncensored for reason I
don't believe in self-censorship I don't
believe when the Dutch people can read
this information in a book available in
bookstores as some of them had already
bought copies that British people should
be denied that information and the
information by the way is hugely
significant we've waited two and a half
years to find out who these members of
the royal family were that megga Mar
weird people like obession pairs waiting
to no no actually the entire country has
no
misrepresentation of most of the country
what I actually want to know is he said
he had no help from the Sues and yet on
the other hand he said he saw the
letters yeah so how did he see the how
has he got the information exactly he's
not got it from King Charles it's all
come from
[Applause]
[Music]
monito